what up guys welcome to Pearl daily
where I go over this week's treachery
debauchery and craziness before I start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification Bell that
way you're going to be notified of my
daily videos like the video on your way
in let's get started so today we are
going to be talking about how men are
falsely accused their careers are ruined
and oftentimes later it comes out that
they were a hundred percent innocent so
a couple years ago Kevin Spacey was
charged with nine sexual offenses
so recently Kevin Spacey was found not
guilty of sexual assault so guys what is
sexual assault again the feminist
infiltrated the legal system and it
brought in all of these definitions that
we don't know what they mean so they
essentially expanded the definition of
sexual assault rape this is what they do
they come into these these spaces and
change the definitions and make them
more subjective not objective so it's
more subjective whether or not someone
was sexually assaulted like think about
it guys what is sexual assault even mean
what does it even mean dude like just
off the top of your head we should know
in a society what words mean but what
the feminists do is they get into these
systems change the definitions and
confuse everybody so Kevin Spacey was
acquitted of all nine charges related to
sexual offenses the celebrated
oscar-winning actor Kevin Spacey
initially faced 12 charges when the
trial commenced at London southwarks
Crown Court three of these charges were
dropped during trial the charges which
included seven counts of sexual assault
were made by four men claiming the
incidents occurred between 2001 and
2013. Kevin Spacey endured false
accusations that shattered his life and
led to his removal from the Hollywood
scene ultimately after many years he was
found not guilty however the questions
arise will he be able to reclaim that
time and money lost during this ordeal
regrettably the answer is no
highlighting the fact that women can
inflict irreparable damage on men's
lives without facing consequences this
situation brings to mind the Andrew Tate
and Tristan Tate case which the media's
Relentless attacks have been truly
horrendous proving their innocence may
take a few more years subjecting them to
similar harrowing experiences as
spacey-faced but the lack of
accountability for those who make false
accusations can have devastating
consequences for the Innocents while
they face zero repercussions
so in 2017 when all of these allegations
against Kevin Spacey come out Kevin was
dropped from Netflix this man worked his
entire life to get a deal with Netflix
and he was dropped now half a decade
later this guy has been fighting these
allegations and it comes out that all of
these charges are false now you know I
recently tweeted believe no women and
you know maybe there's a little bit of
satire but the point of the matter is we
are supposed to live in a society that
is innocent until proven guilty but time
and time again organizations treat men
that are accused of crimes as guilty
until innocent and my question is should
we hold the companies accountable that
fire these men before they are given a
trial and jury of their peers it's one
thing if the men are found guilty but
they're firing and removing men from
organizations and institutions before we
even have a verdict is that fair to the
men and do you think we would have that
same energy if women were accused of a
crime if women are accused of a crime do
you think that they would be so quick to
remove us from organizations and
institutions and the answer is no I mean
I I don't need to study or data to tell
you this guys the left will be like
Source what's your Source I have eyes
and the truth of the matter is that
women accused of crimes do not face the
same repercussions that men of accused
of crimes have and my question at the
end of the day is how seriously should
we take accusations of assault even if
it's from multiple women what I've found
is people that come out years later why
did you wait years I'll give you guys
like three months to come out should we
really take seriously people the that
claimed they were assaulted 10 years ago
15 years ago should there be a cap on
how long you can take to accuse someone
of assault and what is assault you know
I and I think this is what the feminists
do they change the definitions of words
to make us more victims because they
just have this a narrative that men are
abusers men are evil and if you give men
power they're going to sexually assault
coerce rape whatever it is but then they
change the definition of those words to
include things like getting your butt
cracked now I'm not saying that's okay
or not okay but like is that the same
thing as rape guys they don't include a
lot of the times that the women were
flirting too the women were playing into
it and my question is as a chick if
you're going to work dressing like a
hooker all right if you're going to work
acting like a hooker can we really blame
the men if they get confused and think
maybe you're kind of loose you know it's
like it's like women will dress so
provocatively and then get mad if men do
anything it's like
it's just craziness and women should
have repercussions for falsely accusing
men of crime crimes no I do not think
this will lead to women that really were
raped and really were assaulted to not
come forward I think women that these
terrible things have happened to will
have evidence on their side to prove
this kind of thing and I think there
needs to be a push for laws to be passed
that make the definitions very clear and
less subjective and also get laws passed
where there are repercussions for women
falsely accusing men I think those two
things would solve a lot of the issues
we got to get rid of these subjective
words like coercion consent manipulation
it's like those are all subjective like
if I
if I am dating a guy and he convinces me
to go to cam work in Romania is that
coercion
or a good salesman you know what I mean
and this is this is what I mean it's
like when we get to all these
subjectivity no rape is forced sex
that's it all of these other oh
no four sex either he forced you to have
sex or he didn't and I think when we get
in the weeds of all this whining and
complaining and accusing men of thinking
doing things they didn't do I think it's
very confusing for the women and I think
it's and it's very confusing for society
because now we don't know the difference
between a woman that actually was raped
and a woman that is just crying Okay so
Jason Aldean is really one of the
greatest country artists of Our
Generation honestly growing up when I
was in high school that was all
everybody listened to Jason Aldean Luke
Bryan I've always been a really really
big country fan so Jason Aldean recently
released a song called try that in a
small town and this song basically
detailed how there's a lot of crime
going on in the cities a lot of you know
nonsense they're like burning the cities
down robbing I mean every day on Twitter
I see another clip of just homeless
people in all the cities in America
tents I see them
robbing stores looting and Jason
released a song saying try that in a
small town buddy good luck it basically
is talking about how none of the [__]
they get away with in the cities would
fly in a small town everyone's got guns
everybody kind of polices each other try
that in the country and the left freaked
out calling Jason a misogynist a racist
and
it's crazy because really the song is
let's not commit crimes that's not going
to work where I'm from so I mean what's
the negative message about this
I mean I didn't hear him mention race
Jen I didn't I didn't hear him mention
race once he's talking about criminals
committing crimes
yet the woke left is just common for
Jason
saying that now he's a racist so much so
that he recently had to remove all black
lives matter protests from this music
video
and now we're getting to a point where
we can't even talk about reality
uh without being called racist sexist
homophobic anti-semitic it's like they
always throw one of these terms at you
when you say speech that is not accepted
by the left
Jason Aldean actually has a new song
that he was really sorry and apologetic
and just very very you know sorry and I
guess he maybe he bent a little bit to
the Mob but he came out with a new song
his new song is called go woke go broke
and seriously think about how where we
have to be in society how fed up we are
with this woke [__] where we're
mentioning companies in country music
like country music you guys already know
the stereotypes is typically about a
girl beer farming and now it's like the
country people are so gosh darn sick of
this liberal nonsense just nonsense just
shove down our throats that we are now
creating music to fight back against
this stuff music really does represent
the culture I mean when you think about
it and I think about stuff like this a
lot like you you see what is going on in
society when you see what music is
popular because those are stories people
can relate to so think about it Taylor
Swift is popular because there is a
whole generation of heartbroken chicks
and that's why you see your concerts
just filled with these single chicks cat
ladies screaming and I'm sorry I do kind
of like Taylor Swift she's a really good
artist but it's true when we say music
reflects society and I really think
there's going to be a whole wave of
anti-woke music to just fight against
this [__] that has been shoved down
our throats for the past hundred years
and making us put up with not being able
to call out criminals
um and also Force feeding this woke
propaganda you know I love Target guys
do you know how much I get so many
clothes from Target and now I have to go
to Target and see fat models I have to
go to Target and see gay propaganda in
the kids section it's like this [__] is
everywhere people are sick of seeing it
to the point we have music dedicated to
it so you know on a lot of these shows
that I go on and talk on you see women
talk about how men don't care about
promiscuity anymore and you know I'm
actually gonna play devil's advocate
here because again men do adapt to the
market okay men don't want promiscuity
but most men don't think they're gonna
marry a virgin
right and that that shows that men do
adapt to the market so if all the women
are not virgins they're like fine I'll
take not a virgin if all the women are
[__] you're gonna see Horrors get wife
here and there right because you know at
the end of the day men do want hot
chicks so they'll put up with a lot
however to act like there's no
consequence to any of this stuff that
you can really do whatever you want as a
chick and there's always going to be a
man to date you at the end of the day
and in my opinion it's not even about
the men
um it's more about the damage you do to
yourself because after you're a chick
and you've done only fans corn you've
slept with a million people how are you
gonna bond with your husband and at the
end of the day our habits make us who
you are and if you've spent 10 years
drinking every day
why you don't think it would be hard for
you to stop but for some reason with
women it's like if we have spent a
decade of our lives with multiple men
getting attention from all these
different guys it's like you don't think
that's gonna change our brain a little
bit
you don't think that's going to make it
more difficult
um and and I've thought about this a lot
where if men it's like there's positive
reinforcements for women to get big on
social media to get take off our clothes
like we are paid to do this stuff
imagine if the imaginative men were paid
to watch corn because really social
media is to women as corn is to men
right you guys know what that stands for
so it's like what if men were paid to do
that stuff what would happen to the men
in society right now it's not paid right
but you see a lot of guys are addicted
to that stuff and it's free and you
could argue that they're only addicted
to it because of the the market of women
like we have the growing increasing
number of male virgins that the left
will just tell you doesn't exist and
it's just these weirdos so my point is
we have all these positive
reinforcements for women doing something
that is very addictive to us and hurts
our ability to stay with a husband long
term we have an older corn star Adriana
chechik talking about what dating is
like in her position now she is known
for I guess doing a lot of crazy stuff
online some wild scenes and she talks
about it here what that has led to for
her in the dating Market
I find it incredibly hard to date to the
point where I actually like can't get
dates so there's two perspectives on
that so if I were to go meet somebody
it's kind of hard because I don't like
random people to know my real name so
obviously I'm meeting them as Adriana
chechik and that's extremely hard it's
intimidating
um I've had guys literally walk out on
me when I've met them because they're so
intimidated me and then also I've done
some of the most extreme sex accident
camera that guys can't swallow or get
past I currently do kind of look like a
little bit of a lonely dive there's
another aspect where the guys only want
to date me to like show show me off to
other people or their friends they
immediately treat me like the Adriana
Adriana chechik like experience right so
like if I was gonna go meet a guy like
they would never hold my hand or
anything the first thing they do is they
try and like have sex with me so it's
really like disheartening to be honest
and I've kind of just given up I feel
like sadly I actually feel like I might
not ever find like a boyfriend like that
so there you have it folks from the
horse's mouth
doing corn
will make it tougher to date and I think
it really I really think love is a Young
Person's game I think over a certain age
honestly the chance of finding like true
genuine like love it like there's a
reason all like Romeo and Juliet weren't
55. there's a reason all of these love
stories it really wasn't old people it
was younger people and the more as a
women you destroy the youth and the
beauty that God gave you and the
Innocence then the more you're gonna
have a hard time in dating and it's
really like playing roulette you might
be able to get away with it some chicks
do they're hot enough but you know
you're really playing with fire when you
when you open the door to doing sex work
and I think it's a bit disingenuous to
say that oh I know porn stars that have
been married oh I know only fans workers
that get married right but do they
typically stay married to the same
person for a lifetime I I I don't really
see that I don't know any 70 year olds
married old porn stars but let me know
in the comments maybe it's just out of
my circle
you know all these happy hookers just
married
so
can women do it all
the job the family
can women really have everything
the first black woman CEO in a Fortune
500 company on work-life balance you
don't have to go to all your kids's
games she said the pressure of having it
all is still alive and well many working
mothers bear a heavier burden when it
comes to balancing their careers and
families but former Xerox CEO or celeb
berms who became the first black CEO of
a Fortune 500 company in 2009 says she
never bought into that narrative rather
she says she relied on her late husband
Lloyd Bean to help take care of her two
children missing activities for work
while scaling the career ladder and she
credits her Career Success to strategy
so it's really interesting though it
like this this point of view because
you know this is a modern woman that
accepted what came with it she got a
house husband
now my thing is like if you're gonna
make a ton of money as a chick and be
that boss CEO I don't know why you would
expect a guy to make more than you you
know what I mean it's like and on one
hand I'm gonna give her her props she
did accept what came with it however she
said I would not be able to be the CEO
of the company unless I outsourced the
caring for my kids so we're getting to a
point where we are Outsourcing
motherhood and you know at the end of
the day kids don't need
money
they don't need to be rich what kids
need is parents involved parents and I
do think it's more important that the
mother is home than the father is home
because the family unit in general this
is an exception will not survive if the
husband does not put his career first
but
the family unit at home does not survive
if the woman is not there to transplant
culture and values and this is the this
is the thing too
a lot of times we live in a society
where money is the most important thing
where my question is is money more
important than raising your kids
correctly so burn 63 tells CNBC make it
I was not a believer that you had to go
to all of your kids's games I just don't
understand what that's all about that
mindset Burns said promoted negative
feedback from other parents but it
worked for her even when she attended a
game she says she didn't watch every
second of it instead she used the time
to relax and do a crossword puzzle how
crazy is that it's like she comes to the
game she won't even watch it it's still
about what she should do with her time
and this is the problem it's my career
before the family it's my crossword
puzzle and what I want to do before the
family and she says I wasn't a
helicopter mom we did what we had to do
burns LED Xerox from 2009 to 2016 when
the company split into two corporate
entities
Xerox and conduit she remained xerox's
chairman until 2017. you know it's funny
I used to work and copier sales so I
actually I know Xerox pretty well is a
company and I'll tell you they are known
for being [__] at least when I worked
this was like two three years ago Xerox
was like if I walked into a company with
Xerox I knew that I could I could steal
the business Canon was a different story
Canon was rough that was that was the
hard competition she says that when she
started to rise up the corporate ranks
beans a research scientist at the same
company retired early to become a
stay-at-home dad Burn's sister also
lived nearby and sometimes helped out
Byrne said and I also wonder like a lot
of times I think about this stuff and I
think was she really more competent than
the husband or did they just have a
quota they needed to fill
because that's what they do with women
and these like are women really great
managers and CEOs
sorry guys I'm a sexist I don't know
what to tell you she credits the
collective approach to her ability to
lead Xerox while simultaneously having
multiple kids in the house it takes a
village it takes a village in 2009 she
was appointed by President Barack Obama
to help lead the White House National
stem program which encourages students
to pursue STEM related career she was
later appointed to the vice chair of the
president's expert Council a role she
had from 2015 to 2016. she also served
on the board of directors of multiple
corporations including Uber American
Express and Exxon Mobil and 2014 to
Forbes rated her the 22nd most powerful
woman in the world despite missing out
on after school activities burn says she
raised two unbelievably good kids at the
same time she says her career Ascent
moved so quickly that it sometimes left
her feeling absent from the regular
emotions of her day-to-day life her only
regret not being more present in those
Daily Motions from the office to her
home so this is the thing guys
everything comes at a cost you can't
have everything and I will give her her
credit she did accept what came with it
she married down which really if you're
in that position it's like
if that's what she wants to do she
accepts what comes with it but it'd be
really interesting to see how the kids
turned out they may have turned out okay
but in my opinion you're kind of playing
with fire because when you Outsource
motherhood you don't know who's
influencing your kids and we're getting
to a point where we really think that
leading a copier company look at I have
been in The copier business
I promise you this is not this is not
what you want to do with your life oh my
gosh it is not and it's like now it is
your children your legacy
or selling copiers which that business
is kind of going downhill anyway I I
mean again to her credit she married
down seems like she did the best she
could but the whole point of this is you
literally cannot have everything
everything you pick comes with the cost
and Men accept this but women sell this
stream that you can have everything when
even the CEO of Xerox will admit that
going home she was not present for her
children and what I really do appreciate
is she's honest about this because
someday the kids do talk and they give
their side of the story and a lot of
times it's not the story that all of
these mothers have been screaming that
they just did everything and did it well
so this is the thing guys everything in
life comes at a cost
um and usually the cost is to your kids
so the question is was the benefit did
it really outweigh the cost
um I don't know I think in most cases
for the average chick it does not I
think it does not but let me know what
you guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out guys and let me
know what you want me to cover next on
Pearl daily subscribe to the channel
I'll talk to you next time